What happens when five male cadavers are put
through SCP-914?
Dr. Grangan decided to find out.
The first cadaver was placed in 914 on the
setting “Rough.”
The output was a pile of human limbs, organs,
and bones, all separated via apparent tearing
and heat.
Dr. Grangan described this as “unsettling.”
The next cadaver was run through on “Coarse.”
What emerged was a pile of human remains,
with the organs and bones removed via a cutting
tool, and the skin, nervous system, digestive
system, and circulatory system were removed
with no damage at all.
The third cadaver was placed in 914 on “1:1.”
Though the cadaver that went in was Caucasian,
the one that came out was an Asian man.
The next cadaver went in on “Fine.”
It emerged with SCP-008 inside of it.
The body was immediately destroyed.
The final cadaver was placed in 914 on the
setting “Very Fine.”
The output was green slime, with the properties
and chemical structure of SCP-447-2.
The O5 Council declared that no more cadavers
were to be tested in SCP-914.